dixième sur le député merci la parole et
à monsieur damien abad
merci monsieur le président d'abord vous
dire c'est quand même un comble qu'on
ait un ministre de l'agriculture qui
n'osent même pas aller au congrès de la
fnsea
franchement monsieur le ministre on
aurait mérité mieux que ça les
agriculteurs mérite beaucoup mieux que
ça ma question s'adresse
il vous plaît à l'ensemble des ministres
de l'économie du quinquennat au nahd qui
ont tous un point commun c'est qu'ils
ont tous des serres déserté aujourd'hui
les bancs de l'hémicycle
la cour des comptes et bruxelles vient
malheureusement encore une fois de vous
décerner un carton rouge celui bien sûr
d'un déficit au dessus de la barre des 3
% en 2017
on est loin des promesses de 2012 mais
vous me direz on n'est plus à une
promesse prêts non tenues
la france est victime d'un triplé gauche
taz un décrochage économique bien sûr
commercial avec un déficit commercial
record mais aussi d'un décrochage
budgétaire vous avez promis la maîtrise
la dette
elle a explosé entre 2012 et 2017 plus
de 325 milliards d'euros et ceci alors
même que vous avez augmenté les impôts
et matraquer fiscalement les ménages
vous avez promis une dépense publique
est maîtrisée
la france reste malheureusement l'un des
plus mauvais élèves en europe
et ce sans qu'on ait de meilleurs
résultats en termes d'éducation de
formation de logement nous aviez promis
la fameuse inversion de la courbe du
chômage et bien françois hollande
emmanuel macron et consorts c'est
finalement plus de 1,1 million de
demandeurs d'emploi supplémentaires
depuis 2012 vous avez promis enfin la
réduction du déficit public
là aussi vous avez réussi à nous placer
la france
lanterne rouge en europe malgré des
facteurs favorables alors nous étions
déjà en europe le pays qui affiche le
nombre de chômeurs le plus important la
croissance la plus faible et la dette la
plus abyssal nous avons désormais le
déficit extérieur le plus important
alors vivement que ce quinquennat
s'arrête l'héritage budgétaire sera très
lourd monsieur le premier ministre qui
est comptable de ce bilan monsieur hamon
monsieur mais il réunit la parole est à
monsieur christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget et
des comptes publics
je le président mesdames messieurs les
députés monsieur le député damien abad
vous évoquez trois sujets je vais les
évoquer très précisément et très
simplement
1 le déficit du commerce extérieur
le déficit du commerce extérieur
viendrait annoncé à hauteur d'environ 45
milliards d'euros en 2016
monsieur abad en 2000 or combien était
le déficit du commerce extérieur 75
milliards monsieur abad et si
aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui 45 milliards
c'est insupportable alors 75 milliards
en 2011
nous devions être mort monsieur aba'a
deuxième sujet la dette publique
monsieur abad la cour des comptes est
juge de paix les lois de règlement sont
juges de paix la dette publique monsieur
abad
elle a augmenté sous ce quinquennat de
8% monsieur abad
savez-vous de combien la augmenté au
cours du quinquennat précédent 25%
monsieur à battre
quatre fois plus quatre fois plus ce
monsieur va troisième sujet troisième
sujet le déficit public monsieur abad
déficit public sera nous serons
définitivement au mois de mars autour de
69 milliards d'euros vous pouvez dire
que c'est insupportable en 2010 monsieur
abad sous votre majorité
il a atteint quasiment 150 milliards
le double alors monsieur à battre
monsieur à battre votre esprit
revanchard ne vous autorise pas à
raconter des bobards
[Applaudissements]